this is our personal archive footage
that we are sharing with the world
[Music]
can you believe we got married three
times you are cordially invited to
relive Kourtney Kardashian and Travis
Barker's weddings all three of them I
mean it's a beautiful thing the couple
is sharing private never-before-seen
wedding footage in a new special titled
till death do us part Courtney and
Travis set to air on Hulu on April 13th
it's like choosing a child I can't pick
the best one Vegas was like our Wild
Rock Star wedding
Santa Barbara was like as traditional as
like everybody else's wedding could have
been
anything that's what we say about oh
yeah that's what's coming and then Italy
was just really romantic and classic
yeah the reality star in the Blink 182
drummer said I do three times I guess
what happens in Vegas doesn't always
stay in Vegas first in an unofficial
ceremony in Las Vegas after the Grammys
in April 2022. you did a practice run on
the wedding congratulations thank you
did you walk down the aisle yes you can
please tell me you have videos of this
but I blacked out I actually don't
remember though about 12 30 on I guess
Monday morning I got a call to the
celebrity want to get married they
didn't tell me who it was they just said
a celebrity and we need Elvis we knew
that Elvis had to marry us I didn't even
remember
walking down the aisle I just didn't
remember I didn't remember I had a
bouquet after that they went took the
fresh roses out front and did the
bouquet toss
and they they left shortly after all
that the two made it official with an
intimate courthouse wedding in Santa
Barbara in May before flying overseas
and tying the knot in front of their
close friends and family in Portofino
Italy
felt like I had so much anxiety oh I
feel like shaky because it's such a
vulnerable moment you're sharing I just
felt like I'm about to marry like the
love of my life and then it was like oh
my God I'm about to marry the love of my
life and then all of a sudden the couple
exchanged vows at the estate of Domenico
Dolce and Stefano Gabbana we provided
the feeling and the vibe and then really
trusted Dominico to like carry it out we
wanted it to feel authentic quartz
kiddos Mason Penelope and rain as well
as Travis's kids Landon Alabama and his
stepdaughter Atiana were all by their
side I was nervous and I knew I'm not
going to be able to say my vows without
crying
there's really no love story like you
guys I love you so much it's not even
the martini talking at the time A source
told E.T the couple couldn't be happier
adding that the Italy wedding was
everything they ever wanted our wedding
felt like time didn't exist and it just
felt perfect
foreign